françois mitterrand en amérique latine
le président de la république est
aujourd'hui en équateur et au cours de
sa dernière conférence de presse il a
répondu à nos confrères journalistes qui
s'inquiétait de sa santé comment ça va
monsieur le président recevoir
c'est l'impression en tout cas voyez
ceux qui ont encore des leviers de ce
fils que les mails et bien d'autres
choses
avec donc j'ai l'impression d'avoir l'un
des plus d'installations donc
imprévisible puis ça s'est arrêté là
donc je continue tout à fait normalement
ce voyage qui comme tous les voyages des
étrangers est un voyage rempli
d'obligations que j'accomplis avec
plaisir vous avez vous eu le plaisir
d'autres 1 pour le reste
j'ignore
autant que vous 1 est ce que vous vous
portez bien
comment ses rivaux de marc voilà voilà